the house itself Committee Chairman
Devin Nunez he blasted the Justice
Department yesterday during an interview
claiming that some within the DOJ
they're hoping Republicans will actually
lose the house in the midterm elections
he also said that if there was evidence
the Russians were colluding with the
Trump campaign in 2016
Congress would have been briefed on it
at the time which they were not now
remember it was chairman Nunez back in
2014 he sounded the alarm about Russia's
malicious intent to cause chaos around
the world and yeah in our very own
elections here now is the house Intel
committee chair Devin Nunez so with all
this talk about meddling and
interference it happened at least in a
way that happened in 2012 you warned the
Obama administration very publicly in
2014 and now we're supposed to act
surprised that it all happened although
you know it was under Barack Obama's
watch not Donald Trump yeah Shawn look I
think I warned them not just in 2014 but
very specifically in 20 2016 where I
called it the largest intelligence
failure since 9/11 our failure to
understand Putin's plans and intentions
and remember by that time we had seen
the Russians actively involved in many
elections around the globe so they were
actively trying to interfere in
elections in Eastern Europe and and some
of the former Soviet states so this was
nothing new at all and when I was what
I'm most upset about in this whole
situation of many things but when you go
back to that time period is how they
were able to ignore the warnings that we
were sending from the House Intelligence
Committee and then lo and behold after
they lost the election they first tried
to blame fake news and then when that
didn't work they switched it into this
whole concept of Russia so this is a big
point to is that there were any
collusion certainly you would have known
about it at the time and if anything had
come out between now and then you would
have seen that as you have seen almost
everything from so the question is why
is the witch-hunt going on and and how
do you
look at the molar indictments then of
these twelve Russians that are the
equivalent of our CIA operatives they're
never coming to America there's never
going to be a trial Muller you know
indicted these bot companies thinking
they'd never respond now he's asking the
judge in that case if they could
literally not turn over any documents in
other words that there won't be any
disclosure and remember and remember so
it's not just about the warnings that I
gave in two thousand fourteen fifteen
and sixteen it is also a fact that a
year and a half ago the House
Intelligence Committee had more than
what's in the molar indictment of the
twelve Russian officers okay so we had
more information than that now and we
put it in our report in March it was in
our report that was made public in April
that's heavily redacted remembered by
the Department of Justice and FBI but we
had all this information and so you know
the thing that I brought up is I just
find the timing of this to be very hard
to believe right now you might give them
the benefit of the doubt but why does
this always happen every time something
happens on one side where we find out a
new revelation about what appears to be
to be real problems in the FBI and DOJ
with this investigation then all of a
sudden they drop an indictment it's
happened time and time and again just
this one is really bad so this is what I
want to ask you do you think they're
trying to literally as you said that you
believe the FBI and DOJ they're
obstructing in terms of doing what is
there what your authority
constitutionally is oversight and they
have been obstructing the entire way and
now there's talk about actually
impeaching rod Rosenstein and there's
talk about holding these people in
contempt and you say they're really
doing this hoping the Dems take over
Congress and that it all ends then it's
the oldest trick in the book so many of
the bureaucracies here in Washington
know how to wait out Congress they know
to try to plan meetings on a Friday when
they know there's not votes or on a
Monday when there's not votes they've
all you know that's the time that they
want to give things they wait they know
that Congress is going to adjourn next
week and so the more that they delay for
no reason we're wait
on many documents as you know we're
getting very slow snail-paced
cooperation that is clearly designed to
wait until next week when Congress
adjourns now I have news for them
they're still gonna get to come in and
give depositions they may think they're
not going to but they're going to be
coming in to give depositions throughout
the summer and that's part of the 42
names that I sent to chairman Gowdy and
chairman Goodlatte so I have every
expectation that there will be many
opportunities for these 42 individuals
to come to Congress even though they
have tried to wait us out
and I think they don't think they are
they'd love to see Republicans lose and
and I say that I don't want to I hate to
say that but I have to believe the
Department of Justice and FBI that
people are the leadership they are they
are banking on a loss by the Republicans
in the fall which is why people have to
understand how important it's going to
be to get out and vote in this election
to ensure that the members of Congress
are returned that are actively involved
to ensure because if the Democrats get
control they're gonna drop all of this
investigation they're not going to do
anything on the surface they'll cover up
the whole the biggest this was about
literally trying to steal a presidential
election they'll stop at all I hope you
do hold them in contempt and if it needs
means impeachment then that must be done
otherwise no congressional subpoena will
ever have any teeth to it ever it'll be
the end of it mr. chairman thank you for
being with us